So, innovators like you are creating the jobs that will foster our recovery...
...in creating the technologies that will power our long-term prosperity.
So, I thank you for your work.
You know, it's said that necessity is the mother of invention.
At this moment of necessity, we need you.
We need some inventiveness.
Your country needs you to create new jobs and lead new industries.
Your country needs you to mount a historic effort...
...to end once and for all our dependence on foreign oil.
And in this difficult endeavor,...
...in this pursuit on which I believe our future depends,...
...your country will support you,...
...your president will support you.